was jetzt wichtig ist dass wir diese
airberlin bilder die man mal gucken wie
man aus dem flugzeug gegangen
somit und das outfit seht ihr in 321
letzte deutsche post geht ab und
herzlich willkommen bei einem neuen
video printe und was soll das also was
geht ab ich hasse das wenn das bild so
ist dass man die ärmel vom t shirt nicht
intensiv ist sicherlich weil dann sich
das erste mal cacaus also sieht
eigentlich aus das ist nämlich sehr
wichtig denn heute geht es um outfits es
geht um einen ganz besonderes outfit ich
weiß nicht ob wir das video von ungefähr
vor keine ahnung ein zwei wochen gesehen
habt da haben wir ein ruhig outfit
bestellt also auf der seite ein outfit
für ich glaube 40 euro oder so ohne
versand und dieses outfit ist jetzt
angekommen zumindest fahrt bei einer
sache da frage ich mich wo ist sie weil
die ist ich kann nicht mal kurz das
musst du also ich kann euch hier mal
kurz einen screenshot einblenden und
zwar bezieht sich das ganze auf die
schuhe dann steht am 17
vierter bewerber april am 17 vierten
ausgeliefert das ganze also vorgestern
problem ist keine schuhe da ob die post
wurde die jetzt so schön fand dass er
sich wieder vollkommen die benutze ich
selber weiß ich nicht der ist es da das
klingt ein schlag für unser heutiges
model
wie war noch mal der name so weiter weiß
ich nicht wie das auch gut aussieht
nachher stimmt also nicht stimmt stimmt
das war nämlich die challenge schon fast
vergessen wo das ist ja deswegen nicht
sagen gar nicht lange und mal schauen ob
das gut aussieht wie schon gesagt ihr
müsst euch einbeziehen die einfach
irgendwelche der meisterschule und so
weiß dass jetzt der posten geschossen so
deswegen würde sagen
und hier haben sie nicht sagen und was
hier haben wir sollten auf dem start
steht sieht aus wie der decken die
schrift war deswegen überhaupt frei
leute ich habe es wird irgendwie angst
das brauchen wir den stoff her ist aber
echt richtig eklig oder über und meine
freunde meine hände sind schon richtig
irgendwie davon ab wer so was ein kind
einkaufen und verantwortlich auf jeden
fall happy das video ist echt extrem
klein also das könnte präsident keine
ahnung gut haben wir schon mal
als nächstes haben wir hier ein kleines
paket ja leute hier ist die kette drin
obwohl das geht sogar oder das schon
hart dass ich echt brutal nach china
ich finde es nicht das haben wir dieses
wunderschöne paket selbst die jacke
sowas auch das hier jetzt
die jeansjacke hier kann es auch
brauchen leute die sich aus der kris
jetzt richtig das internet macht
dass wir diese airberlin werden die man
nur kommen aus dem weg gegangen
so leute uns haben wir doch eigentlich
ein bisschen dunkler so also jetzt haben
wir alles bis auf die schuhe schuld
warte mal ich glaube ich hatte auch noch
einen pulli bestimmt dann haben die zwei
sachen nicht mitgeschickt leute ich weiß
es gar nicht ich muss das mal nachgucken
optimal ist das jetzt an sich ein outfit
das outfit
okay das outfit hat also offiziell so
viel geld ich muss das wahrscheinlich
ganz herzlich im kopf sein und wie es
wird jetzt mal kurz auf die andere
kamera und schauen dann mal wie das
aussieht so leute also marie zieht das
ganze gerade an
was hast du gesagt es stinkt übertrieben
was stehen die meisten also ich suche
noch kurz schule damit das weiße schuhe
so wir nehmen diese schuhe dazu ihr
müsst euch vor ständige ich bestellt
habe das waren eigentlich ähnliche die
hatten unglaublich so eine goldene
schleife oder so haben 15 euro kostet
fußball ja mach doch so seid ihr bereit
ziehen heute erst noch kurz die dienstag
raus war erstmal nur gucken wir wie das
mit dem t shirt aus südwest somit und
das outfit seht ihr in 321 letzte also
gehen ein bisschen weiter zurück aber
ein bisschen noch da hinten
vor 20 jahren sind die solar ständig auf
diesem shirt könnte einfach da geht
stehen und das ist eigentlich glaube ich
genau die gleiche schrift meinst du das
shirt ist irgendwie zu klein so oder das
extra erwarte leute und hier macht man
die kette hier raus heute schaue ich mal
hier die kette angeht ist das jetzt die
eine von den ketten
ach so ja gestimmt ist mit 2 1 und wenn
man genau hinschaut waren es sogar zwei
ketten
also werden wir zwei ketten gut und
jetzt damit ziehe man auf die
winterjacken ishizaka ein zimmer die
jeansjacke school weiter warten
zeig dir mal hier in die kamera so steht
er irgendwas drauf aber ich sag mal so
also die finde ich auch eigentlich gut
ich bin ja und ich finde das sieht so
ein bisschen aus wie also könnte werden
von gestern
wenn du das jetzt bewerten ist es was
gibt es für eine note von 1 bis 10 für
alles zusammen
ach so leute hier erst mal kurz nur ein
kleiner outfit von so etwas aus ich
beneide ich bin zufrieden mit meiner
bestellung habe ich glaube ich würde das
machen so ungefähr 500 er über das ganze
gekostet ohne versand also was würdest
du sagen das gibt das für eine note die
einst zusammenhang ist also was willst
du am besten ab ja und was findet man
vielleicht ist das ist das sicherste und
jetzt auch noch skala von 1 bis 10 7
ja gut also also ich finde damit kann
man auf jeden fall raus gehen
es sieht man schon ein bisschen billig
aus also jetzt nicht willig so von von
dir her also auf sich gezogen sondern
von den verboten sobald ich werde ich
finde dass es sich auch gar nicht so bin
ich an fühlt sich extrem inkl
also das was mit dem auto video ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen gibt auf
jeden fall ein viertel nach oben
wir fahren morgen nach österreich ja ich
hab gesagt hätte ja sogar mitgenommen
ansonsten sehen wir uns morgen oder
übermorgen wieder keine ahnung ich
wünsche euch noch einen angenehmen tag
folgt mir auch zu instagram gerne und
das war es